[Música]
Boa noite a todos. É um prazer novamente
estar com vocês aqui. Isaac, Rinaldo,
sejam
bem-vindos. Conforme vocês forem
entrando, por favor, coloque o seu oi,
coloque sua boa noite, dê a sua
saudação. Como é de praxa, eu vou
começar respondendo as perguntas que
foram deixadas no
formulário e depois nós vamos partir
para os artigos.
Primeira pergunta, deixa eu ver se tá o
tamanho. Tá bom. Assim acho que fica
melhor. Quais são as causas principais
do aumento do PSA e como baixar os
níveis? Antes de continuar, agradeço ao
Rinaldo por avisar que o som tá OK.
Isaac também me dê o seu posicionamento
se o som está
adequado. Tem várias coisas que aumenta
o PSA, tá? Primeiro vamos definir o que
é PSA. Uma proteína produzida pela
próstata. Ela tem como finalidade atuar
na coagulação do esperma. Então ela tem
uma função dentro do esperma.
Então, os níveis desse dessa proteína
podem se elevar por várias razões. E as
pessoas pensam que é só o câncer, mas
tem muita coisa que aumenta o
PSA. O mais
comum, além do óbvio, que todo mundo
sabe que é o câncer de
próstata, é a hiperplasia prostática
benigna ou HPB se causa do aumento do
PSA. Se a próta tiver muito grande,
mesmo crescimento benigno vai aumentar
essa proteína.
A prostatítica, inflamação da próstata e
muitas vezes tá acompanhada também do
HPB, da hipoplasia, também aumenta
bastante o PSA e muitas vezes deixa as
pessoas meio desesperadas, pensando que
tem
câncer. Então essa é uma causa que tem
que ficar sempre na nossa mente, a
prostatite. Infecções do trato urinário,
né? A prostatite por si só é uma
infecção do trato urinário, mas mesmo
uma cistite ou uretrite pode aumentar o
PSA. Então, não precisa ser
necessariamente uma infecção do tecido
prostático, pode ser uma infecção da
bexiga ou mesmo da uretra, aumentando o
PSA. A atividade sexual, ejaculação
precoce, desculpa, não precoce,
ejaculação recente também são causas
comuns de aumento de PSA. Então, por
isso que o laboratório pede pra pessoa
esperar três dias depois da relação
sexual ou da masturbação para poder
colher o exame. Entre 48 horas e 3 dias
que tem que ficar de abstinência para
acolher o exame de PSA do
sangue. Manipulações urológicas,
procedimentos urológicos ou médicos, né?
toque retal, exame físico, passar um uma
sonda, passar um eretroscópio, né, que é
o aparelho que olhar dentro da bexiga,
fazer
biópsia, eh qualquer tipo de manipulação
urológica pode aumentar o PSA e isso
pode durar alguns dias.
A biópsia, no caso, pode até ficar
semanas aumentado o PSA, em alguns
casos, se tiver prostatite, trauma
pélvico, né? Pessoas, por exemplo, que
andam muito de bicicleta e o selinho da
bicicleta não é adaptado, pode acontecer
sim o p aumentar pelo uso do selim da
bicicleta ou da moto ou mesmo uma queda
a cavaleiro, né? Uma queda que a pessoa
cai e machuca a região pélvica pode
causar aumento transitório do PSA. E a
idade, né? O PSA vai subindo
gradualmente conforme a pessoa
envelhecendo, independentemente de PSA,
independentemente de HPB ou ou
prostatite ou câncer, vai aumentando
progressivamente. E aí nós temos várias
estratégias para baixar os níveis de
PSA. Então, primeiro tentar identificar
a causa que levou esse PS a aumentar e
se essa causa for tratável, né,
obviamente, se houve um trauma, se houve
uma manipulação, se houve um toque
retal, você não tem como tratar isso,
né? Mas se houver uma infecção urinária,
tiver uma
prostatite ou HPB, você pode tratar isso
e observar os níveis de
PSA. E outra coisa, existe hoje algumas
substâncias que sabidamente baixam PSA.
Uma
delas é uma coisa recente aí que saiu
nos últimos meses, é uma fibra, é o
pectazol G, eh, é uma fibra retirada da
maçã, tá? Isso, infelizmente, não tá
fácil de obter. Aqui no Brasil teve uns
pacientes meus que já compraram esse
pectazol
G, só que tem que ser importado e nem
sempre é fácil de importar. Então, o PSA
aumentado que você descartou prostatite,
descartou câncer, descartou HPB ou
confirmou o HPB, mas o PSA alto tá
incomodando ou a pessoa tá com risco de
desenvolver câncer ou mesmo com câncer
inicial você pode usar o pectazol para
reduzir esp.
OK. Obviamente que estilo de vida
saudável vai ser muito bom também para
prevenir o aumento do PSA, como
atividade física, dieta não
inflamatória, redução do estresse e o
sono adequado. Remédios que você compra
na farmácia em qualquer esquina você
pode usar, mas eu não recomendo a
finasterida e a dutasterida, que são
inibidores da C alfa redutase, que são
remédios que mediante o uso por meses
vão reduzir o tamanho da próstata. e
consequentemente em média eles vão
reduzir o PSA pela metade, mas isso pode
mascarar algumas coisas. Então, o uso de
finasterído dastasterido, além de
mascarar um PSA alto, às vezes pode
gerar também uma cina formado síndrome
pósfinasterida, em que os pacientes se
queixam de redução de energia,
depressão, podem ter disfunção erétil,
podem ter queda de massa muscular. A
gente não sabe exatamente quantas
pessoas desenvolvem essa síndrome, né?
Na bula do remédio fala que é menos de
5%, mas se eu fosse falar um número aí
mais baseado na minha experiência,
alguma coisa em torno de 15%.
E temos suplementos também, fora o
pectasol que eu já comentei que é
novidade, os outros, né, mais
conhecidos, né, o
licopeno, extrato de
ã do bacateiro, né, que é rico
no no na
substância
betacitos, o chá verde, o selênio, o sol
palmeto, o pig africano na tiga de
oica, ah, cúrcuma, né, todas essas
plantas. podem ajudar a baixar o PSA,
porém os resultados são variáveis. OK?
Então essa é a resposta para a
pergunta. Próxima pergunta. Berberina,
sirimarina, né? Podem ser usados mesmo
dia? Se sim, com intervalo de quanto
tempo entre uma e outra?
Sim, podem ser utilizados no mesmo dia.
Não há
necessário eh fazer nenhum intervalo
entre uma e outra, não, tá? Elas são
complementares, são substâncias
antiinflamatórias. No caso, nestisteina,
ela é precursora da gluta e também é um
agente fluidificador de secreções e
também ajuda a baixar a
homocisteína. Não há nenhum problema de
ser utilizado no mesmo dia e nem no
mesmo horário, OK?
Silarina é bom para prevenir todos os
problemas nos
rins? Não é uma afirmação correta, né?
Não é recomendada para qualquer tipo de
problema renal. Celimarina é mais para
questões de fígado, OK? Existe algumas
evidências científicas, porém são pouco
limitadas. esteve uma metaanálise do ano
passado que é recente, analisou 41
estudos controlados e randomizados e
constatou que, embora a sinimarina possa
ter reduzido de forma significativa os
níveis de creatinina, né, que é o
marcador principal de função renal, os
efeitos
nefroprotetores não foram claramente
observados. Então isso ainda não é uma
coisa ainda totalmente estabelecida.
Apesar que eu gosto muito da criarina
para a função hepática, ela pode ajudar
secundariamente os rins, mas não é tão
potente quanto o efeito do fígado,
tá? Tem algumas evidências limitadas da
celimarina em situações específicas, por
exemplo, lesão renal aguda em ratos, né?
estudo em ratos que foi induzida a lesão
nos rins, a crimarina mostrou efeitos
protetivos contra a lesão induzida por
paraquate, né, que é um remédio aí usado
em estudos de cobaia. Então, reduziu o
estresse oxidativo do rim e a morte
celular programada, apoptose na
nefropatia
diabética, pacientes diabéticos que têm
doença no rim, algumas evidências
sugerem que a cerimarina pode ser
benéfica nessa situação, estudos
mostrando redução na albumina urinária
após 3 meses de tratamento. Em pacientes
também em pré-eclampsa, que é aquela
pressão alta hipertensiva da gravidez,
né? Em comparação com o NACA
Nestociteíina, a cerimarina teve
benefícios na disfunção renal dessas
mulheres gestantes com pressão alta,
embora o NAC tenha sido mais efetivo na
redução da urea e da creatinina, tá?
Então você pode usar serimar num stack
de suplementos para insuficiência renal,
porém na minha prática eu não tenho
visto assim muito efeito intenso de
suplementos em pessoas já têm inspência
renal, infelizmente, tá?
Então você pode usar NAC, pode usar
criarina, pode usar com enzema Q10, pode
usar eh eu tenho eu tenho uma receita
padrão que eu prescrevo para paciente
com renal, tem piquinogenol, tem
natoquinase, mas infelizmente não é tão
intenso para quem já tem uma renal
já estabelecida.
E a sirimarina pode ter algumas
contraindicações para alguns problemas
renais. Por exemplo, pessoas que têm
insuficiência renal
crônica, eh, em alguns casos pode ser
contraindicado a cerimarina combinado
com a raceteina, tá? Que é um tipo de
meteonina que é minoácido modificado,
tá?
Eh, então tem que tomar esse cuidado aí
com essa
combinação. E pessoas que têm a função
renal muito alterada tem que tomar
cuidado, tem que baixar a dose da
cimarina,
tá bem? Vamos lá, próxima pergunta. Após
comer, fico com uma espécie de catarro
na garganta, pode ter algo a ver com o
limão um? O que pode ser?
Provavelmente não é o limão,
tá? Quais são as principais causas de
catarro? Antes de continuar, deixa eu
dar o boa noite pra Alice Vogel, pro
Isaac e pro Antônio Renato. Então, as
principais causas de catarro após comer
é refluxo
gastrozofágico. Quando o conteúdo ácido
do estômago vai pro esôfago, né, e chega
até a garganta, pode causar irritação e
aumentar a produção de muco. Então
existe um tipo específico, né, de
refluxo que é o laringo faríngo, né, ou
seja, o líquido subiu para o isôfago e
foi parar na laringe e faringe, né? Isso
pode ser visto naquele exame de naso
laringo
faringoscopia que o otorrino faz com
aquele aparelho flexível, né? Então esse
refluxo laringo faríjo ocorre quando o
aço sobe até faringe e laringe e causa
pigarro, sensação de globos, né? que
aquela sensação de ter uma coisa parada,
né, no pescoço e produção de
secreção. Alguns alimentos também pode
estimular a produção de pigarro. São
alimentos ricos em amido, laticínios,
ingredientes picantes, bebidas
carbonatadas, podem aumentar a produção
de muco, não em todas as pessoas, mas em
alguns grupos.
Isso acontece porque esses alimentos
podem estimular a produção excessiva de
muco como uma resposta natural.
Exofagite é outra possível causa, né?
São sintomas com muito muco na garganta,
principalmente após refeições e muita
salivação, tá? Isofagite, a causa mais
comum é a próprio refluxo, né? Mas
existe esofagite por outras razões aí.
Então, por isso nós estamos falando de
maneira mais abrangente. O limão
geralmente não causa catarro. Na
verdade, o limão ele é frequentemente
usado como remédio, como tratamento para
catarro. Ele tem propriedades que
dissolve o muco, deixando ele mais
líquido e fácil de eliminar. Tem ações
antissépticas, faz a limpeza na região.
Ele é rico em vitaminas, como vocês
sabem, e rico em sais minerais.
Então, investigue se você que tá com
problema aí de muco em excesso,
investigue doença do refluxo
gastroesofágico, o refluxo laringo
faríjo que você investiga com otorrino e
verifique se a tua reação não é algum
alimento
específico. A outra causa também poderia
ser uma sinusite crônica com gotejamento
pós-nasal, tá? é outra situação que
poderia causar também esse catarro
excessivo aí, tá? Então, começa a sua
investigação ou com médico mais
generalista ou integrativo ou com gastro
e depois passe para um otorrino se o
gastro não constatar nenhum tipo de
problema.
No Ceará foram descobertos casos de
gripe aviária. Falam que podemos
consumir a carne
contaminada, pois o vírus não sobrevive
ao cozimento. Sua opinião, por favor. E
qual é o que mais transmite a carne e o
ovo da galinha? Se o ovo é contaminado
quando aquecido no bolo, mata o vírus?
Vírus é muito sensível à temperatura,
tá? Então eu não teria nenhum motivo
para desconfiar dessa informação, não,
tá? O cozimento adequado de fato mata
praticamente todos os vírus, né?
Inclusive da gripe aviária. Eu não tenho
razão para dizer outra coisa aqui. Isso
acontece quando os alimentos são
aquecidos numa temperatura de
74ºC. 74ºC para cima, tá?
Inclusive, só um segundo de exposição a
70º C já seria o suficiente se fosse
considerado carne de
frango. Então, para ovos, o
cozimento até que a clara e a gêmea fica
bem firme, né? Então, a gema e a clara
já estão firmes, né? Você já pode
considerar que eliminou o vírus. Bolos,
só se for um bolo muito mal assado que
vai dar problema, tá?
Desde que o o bolo foi cozido de maneira
correta, não esteja cru, atingja essa
temperatura aí de 70 e poucos graus, que
vai com certeza atingir, né, para fazer
um bolo precisa, o vírus vai ser
eliminado, tá? Então, carne e ovos tem
riscos similares, não vai ter uma
diferença grande se você consumir cozido
ou frito. Obviamente que eu não vou
recomendar você usar ovo cru e nem carne
crua de frango, tá?
coma tudo
isso bem cozido ou
frito. Então eu não ficaria em pânico
por causa dessa gripe aviária. Aí, na
verdade, o grande problema dessa gripe
aviária é é dizimar os os rebanhos, né,
daquele país e as regras sanitárias aí
que o pessoal usa como guerra comercial,
né, para poder evitar de um país eh
fazer exportações. Eles criam uma
confusão danada quando cria, quando
observa só um caso, né, da doença.
Ã, próxima pergunta. Não sei porque que
tá rodando
aqui, tá pulando aqui. Ainda indica
integritar. Eu não sei se essa pergunta
aí é um pouco capiciosa no sentido dessa
pessoa que perguntou que eu não viu
nenhum nome. Aliás, eu não vou nem mais
ver o nome de quem tá fazendo as
perguntas, porque eu reparo que tem
gente que não quer se identificar, pode
sentir vergonha, então eu nem vou falar
mais o nome de quem tá fazendo as
perguntas, tá? Então não vi quem é que
fez essa pergunta e a integritar não tem
nenhum motivo para desconfiar deles, tá?
uma empresa que tem mais de 30 anos aí
de mercado, nunca pisaram na bola
comigo. As poucas vezes que o paciente
ficou irritado ali por uma falha de
funcionário, qualquer empresa tá sujeita
a isso, né? Não tem jeito, é impossível.
Qualquer empresa no Brasil que contrata
o funcionário tá sujeito à falha do
funcionário. Então teve algumas
situações poucas, mas foram muito bem
resolvidas.
Lógico, não é uma famaça das mais
baratas, mas é por conta da seriedade
deles, então isso acaba
encarecendo. Então digo, se você teve
alguma experiência ruim com a
integritar, me avise, mas eh todas as
situações aí que foram poucas que
tiveram algum desentendimento, o
paciente ficou chateado e tudo mais, a
gente resolveu de maneira muito simples,
porque eles são muito atenciosos e estão
muito dispostos a resolver os problemas,
tá? Obviamente que mais raramente ainda
tivemos problemas com pacientes que
tinham problemas psiquiátricos e aí nada
poderia agradá-los, né? Então aí não é o
problema da empresa, mas da pessoa que
quer arrumar confusão por qualquer
motivo, muitas vezes por um problema
psiquiátrico mesmo que tem que ser
abordado aí,
né? Boa noite. O que que você acha sobre
o começo XI? Dizem ter muitas bactérias.
Geralmente o sushi é seguro, OK? Se você
tiver num estabelecimento com mínimo aí
de preocupação, né, com a parte
sanitária, você não vai ter problemas.
Os principais microorganismos que você
pode encontrar no sushi e são bactérias
no gênero aeromonas que pode contaminar
fruto do mar cru e isso tá sendo cada
vez mais estudado. A esquericha coli e
os coliformes são detectados em mais ou
menos
2% das amostras em alguns
estudos. A listéria monocitogênes também
é uma outra bactéria que pode contaminar
alimentos cruz ou pouco processados. A
salmonela, o víbrio e os
tafilococosáureos também podem ser
transmitidos pelo sushi e parasitas,
como é o caso do
anisaques. Mas por que que eu digo então
que é seguro? Só falei um monte de nome
de parasita aqui. Ah, porque geralmente
se você for no estabelecimento adequado,
o peixe vai ser congelado a
-20ºC por 7 dias, né? E isso geralmente
já elimina esse problema.
E o vinagre no arroz e sushi, quando
você come sushi, né? Não o peixe na
forma de sahimi, ele cria um ambiente
ácido com pH abaixo de cinco. Isso inibe
o crescimento
bacteriano, ok?
Ã, obviamente o tudo que eu tô falando
aqui em relação a um estabelecimento de
qualidade, certo? Por isso que surgia,
sushi é um alimento caro, né?
Se você for num num restaurante
adequado, obviamente pessoas que têm
sistema imunológico comprometido,
crianças ou idosos ou gestantes podem
ter problemas maiores e devem evitar o
consumo de sushi se estiverem realmente
numa situação mais
fragilizada. Agora, uma coisa que eu
queria falar para vocês, evitem de
preparar sushi em casa.
Porque geralmente você vai comprar
aquele peixe já pronto de sushi do
supermercado e vai guardar os freezerses
domésticos, eles não têm uma capacidade
boa de baixar temperatura de forma
adequada para eliminar parasitas,
tá? Então assim, existe riscos sim, eu
acredito que esses riscos são
mitigáveis, são riscos eh bem
aceitáveis, né? Agora, como tudo na
vida, para correr risco zero, você tem
que eliminar então o consumo do sushi,
né? Seria mesma situação de você ter
risco zero para não ser atropelado. Você
nunca mais vai poder, né, atravessar uma
rua, porque não existe risco zero pra
maioria das coisas,
né? Olha, o Renaldo tá dizendo aqui, já
teve um problema com a integritar,
resolveram com muita tranquilidade.
Então, pois é, problema todo mundo pode
ter, né? Pode, todo mundo pode contratar
um funcionário ruim.
E aí ter que apagar incêndio,
né? Próxima pergunta. Doutor, se a
mulher tiver com infecção urinária,
tiver relações sexuais, depois se tratar
com
antibióticos, existe a possibilidade de
recontaminação pela mesma bactéria ao
ter novamente relações sexuais com o
mesmo parceiro, considerando que o
parceiro ficou assintomático para
infecção
urinária? Veja bem, a maioria dessas
infecções urinárias não é bactéria do
parceiro, tá? Quando eu falo maioria,
maioria esmagadora. Eu não me lembro de
nenhum caso nesses quase 30 anos que eu
tenho de profissão de ter
visto um caso comprovado que foi o
homem. Eu tô falando de infecção
urinária, não tô falando de
infecção do tipo doença venéria, né,
DST. Tô falando de infecção urinária.
Mas eu não me lembro de nenhum caso que
a infecção urinária foi provocada pela
bactéria do homem. Sempre que eu fazer
examin não dá nada, tá? Então, a
bactéria que na verdade tá reinfectando
essa mulher é a bactéria do perínio da
própria mulher, que na hora que o homem
vai fazer relação, ele dá aquela
esfregada no pênis para cima, né, e vai
carregando a bactéria para uretro da
mulher. Mas essa bactéria que ele tá
carregando não é dele, é da própria
mulher, tá? Geralmente 99% das vezes é
isso que acontece, mas teoricamente
existe sim possibilidade do parceiro
passar bactéria que não seja DST. De
novo, eu não tô falando aqui de
gonorreia, uretrite, puclamídia, eu tô
falando de infecção urinária clássica,
tá? Se for gonorre, obviamente
transmissão é sexual e clamídia a mesma
coisa, tá?
Então, os antibióticos que são
utilizados para tratar infecção urinária
na mulher não necessariamente eliminam
as bactérias presentes em outras partes
do corpo. Isso pode também englobar a
flora do parceiro, apesar que eu tô
falando que é muito raro ser a flora do
parceiro, né? Mesmo que o homem
permaneça
assintomático, potencialmente ele pode
carregar as mesmas bactérias na região
genital que podem ser reintroduzidas
durante o ato
sexual. Então, como eu disse, é o mais
comum é que durante a relação sexual, o
movimento do pênis pode empurrar
bactérias na região do perino da mulher,
que ou seja, da própria anatomia da
mulher, né? ou potencialmente do pênis
do parceiro, apesar de que eu falei,
acabei de falar que é raro, paraa uretra
e da bexiga da
mulher. Esse mecanismo é facilitado pela
anatomia feminina, que a uretra é curta
e é muito próxima do anos e do e do
reto, né? Do anos e da ureta, perdão,
desculpa, do anos e da vagina.
Então, as infecções uninárias
recorrentes são principalmente causadas
por reinfecção pela mesma bactéria. E
ter relações sexuais frequentes é um
fator de risco, né, chamada cicitul de
mel, mas geralmente pelas bactérias da
própria
mulher. A higiene inadequada é um fator
de risco. Então, as mulheres que não têm
esses cuidados podem ter mais infecções
do que as outras.
Então, é sempre recomendado que a mulher
que tem essa tendência tome um banho
antes da relação e outro depois e urine
logo em
seguida. E tem mulheres que precisam
tomar antibiótico logo depois da relação
sexual, porque sempre tem insistite
depois que tem a atividade, ok? Então,
existe essa estratégia, ela é aceitável,
uma dose única de macrodantina ou outro
antibiótico após a relação sexual.
E pode ser muito mais interessante isso
do que fazer uso todo dia, né, diário de
uma dose baixa de
antibiótico. Beleza? Próxima
pergunta. Ah, tem uma aqui no meio aqui.
Para higienizar o sabonete de uma outra
pessoa para uso pessoal, molhar com água
fervida limpa as bactérias. Olha,
geralmente as bactérias elas não ficam
na superfície do sabonete porque o
sabonete ele é altamente alcalino, né?
Então as bactérias não conseguem
proliferar na superfície do sabonete por
conta do pH altamente alcalino da do
sabonete, tá? Então não precisa fazer
essa operação toda não. Mas se você
tiver nojo, por exemplo, de pelos, né,
que possam estar no sabonete, você pode
sim fazer essa operação aí de molhar com
água fervida. Tá
bom? Deixa eu até fazer o
seguinte. Eh, é uma pergunta bem
peculiar que eu queria complementar.
Vamos ver se tem mais outras informações
além dessa que eu acabei de passar para
você, mas vamos continuar
aqui. Bem, o o guia que eu acabei de
acessar aqui tá dizendo para enxaguar o
sabonete em água corrente para remover
resíduos, mas não é necessário usar água
fervida, mas você pode utilizar se
quiser, sim. E pode manter o sabonete
submerso na água e bolição por pelo
menos 5
minutos.
Beleza? Bem, vamos pro próximo aqui. Eh,
boa noite de novo. O que você acha sobre
o uso da creatina? Eu falei muito sobre
a creatina, inclusive aqui nas lives
fechadas, né, inclusive na semana
passada eu falei de um estudo usando a
creatina que reduzia o risco de câncer,
né? Não sei se vocês se lembram que eu
falei isso na semana
passada. Bem, quais são então os fatos
sobre creatina? E tem vários vídeos no
canal também, até na comunidade aberta
que vocês podem estar acessando, é só
procurar lá. Sabemos que a creatina
aumenta a massa muscular, aumenta o
líquido dentro da da fibra muscular e
aumenta a força muscular da contração.
Por isso que é um reforço contra a
sacopenia, que é a perda de massa
muscular é muito útil para praticantes
atividade física, especialmente para
idosos. Também tem evidência que a
creatina diminui a inflamação e os danos
celulares causados pelos treinos
intensos. Reequilíbrio o pH muscular,
aumenta a força e energia, como eu já
comentei, tem ação na memória e na
cognição. Também falo sobre isso em
lives na comunidade aberta. Então, a
creatina não é só para massa muscular e
para força muscular, também serve para
aumentar a cognição, tá? E a dose entre
3 a 5 g por
dia. Uso recomendado é de pelo menos 3
meses. Pode ser consumido em qualquer
horário, antes ou depois do treino, até
durante as refeições. Não tem nenhum
tipo de segredo para usar creatina,
apesar que muita gente gosta de usar
antes do
treino. Existe o protocolo de sobrecarga
ou de saturação, que você faz uma dose
mais alta por 5 a 7 dias, que é 0,3 g
por kg de peso. Eu não acho isso
necessário. Eu acho que isso aqui é uma
filigrana
mais. Mas se você quiser fazer esse
protocolo de saturação é 03 g por kg.
Então a pessoa de 100 kg seria uma dose
alta, né? Seria 30 g de creatina em
quatro doses diárias. Então seria 10 g
de praticamente três em três, quatro
vezes ao dia, né? Eu acho desnecessário
fazer isso, tá? Eu acho que você pode
ficar no 3 a 5 g por
dia. Então, como eu disse, você pode
colocar no meio do alimento, você pode
diluir em água, pode diluir em qualquer
líquido,
ã, não há nenhum problema. O sol deve
evitar de utilizar creatina com bebidas
com cafeína e pode ser consumida com
carboidrato e isso pode melhorar a
absorção. E prefira os produtos que
tenha selo
creapuri. Certo?
Vamos paraa próxima
aqui. Palmito etanolamina para modulação
de dor e inflamação
crônicas. Dr. Alan, se possível dar uma
opinião sobre o ativo para tratamento de
dores neuropáticas. Eu tenho usado
bastante esse ativo, viu? na compressão
de nervos e lombagias e possíveis
riscos. OK? Vamos falar sobre
isso. Sabe se existe essa substância
bioidêntica? Não. Esse conceito de
bioidêntico para para o mitoíetan
etanolamina não faz muito sentido, não,
tá? A gente fala de bioidêntico para
hormônios, então é eh não tem essa esse
conceito, não faz sentido,
não. Todos, veja bem, até o hormônio
bioidêntico é sintético, tá? Estão
confundindo sintético com o bioidêntico.
Bioêntico é porque tem estrutura igual
do organismo, mas ele é ele continua
sendo sintético, OK? Então não confunda
sintético com
bioidêntico. Bem, tem alguns estudos que
demonstram a eficácia do peia, né, do
palmitomil etanolamina para dor
neuropática. teve uma metaanálise de 11
estudos, envolveu 774 pacientes, que o
uso do PEA reduziu os scores de dor e
teve significância estatística.
Tem um estudo também para dor
ciática, um estudo duplo cego controlado
pro placebo com quase aí 700 pacientes,
que foi demonstrado que o número
necessário para tratar 50% da dor foi de
apenas 1,5 g após 3 semanas de
tratamento. Então sim, PEIA é eficaz
para doceática.
para compressão do nervo ciático, da
síndrot túm do carp neuropatia diabética
ou periférica, dores lombares e
polineuropatias. O mecanismo da
desinflamação neuronal do
PEA é principalmente as células gliais,
que são as células de suporte dos
neurônios. Então ela acalma as células
gliais, né? bem parecido com o efeito do
LDN, né, do low dose na trexone, a
trexone de baixa dosagem. Então o PE vai
acalmar as células gliis e reduzir a
liberação de substâncias inflamatórias.
Ele atua em vários receptores
canabinóides, CB1, CB2 e o
vanilo1, inibindo a inflamação. Então
ele é muito bem assim casado com o
extrato de cannabis. Eu tenho utilizado
Pea junto com o estrato de cannabis com
bons
resultados e tem um perfil de segurança
muito bom.
Eh, não houve efeitos colaterais
importantes em
estudos desse agente. Uma análise de
quase 1500 pacientes não teve efeitos
colaterais
notáveis e os que foram registrados
foram leves e geralmente
gastrointestinais leves, né? Gastrite,
queimação, peso no
estômago e diarreia, tá? Mas não é
comum. Não há interações medicamentosas
importantes. Você pode combinar com
vários analgésicos comuns, tramadol, que
é o tramal, a pregabalina, a
galvapentina e a duloxetina. Nunca teve
problema de fazer essas
associações. A dose é 600 mg duas vezes
ao dia. Você pode usar até
sublingual ou pode ser usar vioral
também.
Mas se você tá utilizando o PE junto com
outros agentes, você pode reduzir a
dose. Então o suplemento PEA é uma
versão, como eu falei, sintética, mas é
bioidêntico. Você não deve se preocupar
com essa questão do bioidêntico, não,
tá?
Então, eu tenho gostado muito do efeito
do peia. Vamos pra próxima
pergunta. Numa live passada perguntei
sobre a minha vitamina D que estava em
336 nanomoles, que
equivale a Ah, não, você colocou aqui
que o laboratório coloca entre 50 e 200
nanomoles por litro. Estava tomando
10.000 1000 por dia, pois além da doença
autoimune, onde mora é frio, mais de 6
meses por ano. Um reumatologista que
consultei diz que essa dose estava boa e
vejo muitos médicos da medicina
integrativa, incluindo Dr. Berg ou Eric
Berg, né, que tem um material muito bom,
recomendam 10.000 unidades. Isso aí todo
mundo recomenda, inclusive o maioria dos
médicos, o Lair Ribeiro, o Ciro Coimbra,
essa dose padrão de 10.000. Só que eu
não tenho passado para todo mundo essa
dose padrão, não, tá?
O que poderia ter causado os meus níveis
estarem elevados se essa dose é
padrão? É porque você tomou por muito
tempo, provavelmente, né? E outra coisa,
isso é variável. Tem gente que toma
2.000 por dia, já sobe. Tem gente que
toma 20.000 e não
sobe. Meu PTH é de 20, eh, estaria sendo
suprimido, um pouco suprimido, tá? Mas a
quando a gente faz o
protocolo de altas doses, a gente quer
deixar o PTH na faixa de 12. Então, tá
parcialmente suprimido esse nível aí,
tá? Só que não é bom você manter essa
esse nível de 336 nanomoles, que
equivale a 134 ng por ml. Não tem
necessidade de deixar acima de 100 m de
100 no sangue, tá? de 100g por ml ou 336
que seja, porque você não vai ter
maiores benefícios do que tá trabalhando
com a vitamina D em torno de 70, 80 e
pode correr um risco aí de ter uma
calcificação no rim ou na parede da
artéria e não correria esse risco mesmo
que baixo.
OK? Então tome cuidado. 10.000 por dia,
não é seguro para todo mundo. Se você
tomar uns 3 meses, isso daí,
dificilmente você vai ter problema. Mas
vai ter gente que vai tomar seis meses,
um ano dessa dose, vai acumular demais,
certo? Tome cuidado, não tome doses
altas sem acompanhamento com o
médico. Tem muita variabilidade genética
no metabolismo na vitamina D, tá? Tem
que tomar muito cuidado com
isso. Pessoas que tomam diuréticos da
classe dos tiasídicos pode aumentar a
vitamina D, a digoxina também, o
estrogênio pode acontecer isso, tá?
Então, foi correta a suspensão da
vitamina D nesse
caso. Então, pode-se tomar os três
comprimidos criarina, bemina eciteína
juntos de uma vez?
a não ser que você tenha algum
desconforto aí no estômago, aí você toma
em horários
diferentes. Fitoterápico como erva de
São João e mucuna pode ser utilizado por
quanto tempo? Erva de São João é um
fitoráfico particularmente problemático,
tá? Ele é um dos mais inseguros aí.
Então eu não recomendo você utilizar ele
sem
acompanhamento por mais do que meses,
tá? Se tiver com acompanhamento aí vou
não tem problema. Mucuna não, mucuna
prurias é seguro,
tá? O senhor conhece o estudo que
compara em grau de resultado
crocusativos a
ritalina? Não conheço. Deixa eu
levantar essa informação
aqui. Enquanto isso, a gente pra próxima
pergunta.
Depois eu volto nisso
aqui. Netcolina limpa o organismo. Qual
a diferença dela em relação a
cerimarina? Eu acho que tá fazendo umas
confusões aqui, tá? Você tá falando aí
de colina, que tem na fórmula de
fosfatid
colina, tem na fórmula aí
de eh tem várias sal de colina no
mercado, tem
o caramba, me fugiu o nome agora aqui,
mas enfim, você tá falando de colina ou
de necetil cisteína, porque não tem
ncetil colina,
tá? Tem o alfa GPC também, é uma forma
de colina.
Tem o citicolina, que é uma forma de
colina, mas não tem nacetil colina, ok?
A colina, ela tem propriedades de detox,
especialmente
fígado. Ela auxilia no metabolismo de
gordura, previne um acúmulo excessivo,
contribui paraa eliminação de toxinas.
Ela tem um papel muito importante na
produção de fosfolipídeos, que são
gorduras importantes que compõem a
membrana celular, tá? especialmente de
neurônio. Então, e também ajuda a baixar
a homocisteína, né? A colina é um dos
elementos que abaixam a
homocisteína. Então, no sistema nervoso,
a colina atua como precursor da
cetilcolina, que é o neurotransmissor
importante da
memória, e também do controle
muscular, tá? Então, a
colina não tem nada a ver com a
cerimarina.
A colina é um
nutriente e ela é considerada um
componente do complexo da vitamina B,
apesar de não ter esse nome de B alguma
coisa. E aimarina é um fitoterápico, já
é não é um nutriente essencial, é um
fitoterápico, tem outra classificação e
é extraído do cardano, que é a planta,
né?
E enquanto que a colina ajuda no
metabolismo de gordura e no detox é
precursora do neurotransmissor
acetilcolina, a cerimarina é um
antioxidante estabilizador de membrana
de fígado, de hepatócito de célula do
fígado, tá? Ação principal da colina é
eliminação de toxinas e metabolismo
hepático e da crimarina é proteção
contra as substâncias tóxicas e
regeneração hepática. Então os dois vão
atuar num fígado, mas são ações
diferentes, porque a colina não vai só
atuar no fígado, vai atuar no cérebro
também. E a colina é muito usada para
prevenção de esteatose, que gordura no
fígado e para suporte cognitivo,
enquanto que a crimarina é mais para
questões de fígado, né? Mas também pode
ser usado para rim, como foi o tema da
outra pergunta.
As doses da colina é de 250
mg por
dia. A cerimarina de 100 a 500
mg. Efeito colateral da colina pode
acontecer às vezes suá excessivo,
salivação, odor corporal mais forte,
náusea, desconforto gástrico que é de
pressão. Essa marina pode dar também
diarreia, gases, doigo, estômago, boca
seca, náusas, vômitos. de cabeça e
fraqueza. Então, a colina é um nutriente
essencial, é mais seguro pro seu
nutriente e a cinarina é um fitoterápico
que, pela própria definição de
fitoterápico, é menos seguro do que
nutriente, apesar ainda ser muito mais
seguro que droga,
tá? A berberina é boa paraa saúde do
pâncreas e do
rins? Sim. Eh, existe evidência que a
beberina é boa para a saúde do pâncreas.
Os efeitos no rin são mais difíceis,
mais
complexos. Falando sobre o pâncreas, a
beberina, ela pode
proporcionar benefício de controle
metabólico. Ela vai melhorar a secreção
de insulina, vai aumentar a
sensibilidade de insulina. Isso vai
ajudar no funcionamento da parte
endócrina do pâncreas.
Em estudos, a Beberina reduziu a
glicemia de jejum, então eu uso muito
ela para pré-diabetes, para
diabetes. Também reduz a glicemia pós
refeição, pós-prandial, melhora a função
das células
betapancreáticas porque ativa o complexo
AMPK, que é uma enzima crucial, controle
metabolismo
energético. Então, os efeitos principais
no pâncreas da berberina é melhorar a
secreção de insulina, melhorar a
sensibilidade de insulina, reduzão,
reduzir a resistência à insulina,
proteger as células betapancreáticas e
controlar a glicemia. Efeitos nos rins
são menos conhecidos e as evidências são
conflitantes. Então, a bemina pode ter
efeito protetivo no rim por ser
antioxidante e
anti-inflamatória. Pode ter ação
diurética, pode prevenir cálculos
renais, mas as evidências são menores,
tá, do que a ação dela no
pâncreas. Então, potencialmente, a
beberina poderia ter propriedades
antioxidantes protetivas.
efeitos anti-inflamatórios, controle
glicêmico diurético
também. Porém, a beberina pode aumentar
a creatinina, né, que é o marcador de
função renal em alguns
usuários. Então, tem que ficar atento
quanto a isso. Então, pessoas que tm
doença renal crônica, tem que ficar
atentos.
Algumas pessoas com pressão alta, que
tem uma mutação específica, podem ter
aumento de pressão usando beberina.
Então tem que ficar atento quanto a
isso. Tem evidência também que a
beberina modula a microbiota intestinal,
favorecendo bactérias benéficas e
reduzindo a inflamação
sistêmica. OK? É melhor utilizar com
acompanhamento médico.
Ã, dose segura de cimarina que não
prejudica o zim, já falei, tá? 200 a 500
mg por dia. Autistas ou esquizofrênicos
com problemas e sociabilidade deve
tentar forçar a sociabilização ou isolar
ou se isolar.
Bem,
eu
recomendaria não forçar a socialização,
ter acompanhamento de um terapeuta muito
experiente que terapia ABA também
acompanhamento além do psicológico com
aba fono terapia ocupacional e não
forçar a sociabilização, mas ir aos
pouquinhos introduzindo elementos de
sociabilidade sem criar nenhuma crise na
criança, né, ou no paciente, no caso,
tá? Então, tem que ser uma coisa
gradual, muito cuidadosa, tá? Com muita
paciência para não criar crises
nesse indivíduo. Bem, vamos ver alguns
comentários ao vivo
aqui. A fritura deve ser, né? elimina
todos os parasitas e vivos que possa ter
na carne de
porco. Meu pai pegou porque certamente
ele consumiu mil crua essa carne aí,
entendeu? Se você cozinhar bem não vai
ter
problema. Aqui o comentário do
Fernando. A fervura não libera mais
toxinas tóxicas dos sabonetes que não
são orgânicos. Boa
pergunta. Não us sabonete tóxico, né?
Essa que é a
situação. Eu acho que a
fevura é
um cuidado um pouco desnecessário, na
minha opinião, mas a pessoa perguntou e
é aceitável sim jogar a fervura, mas eu
acho um pouco exagero isso
aí. É, Antônio Renato escreveu
ncetilcisteína. Deve ser aquela pergunta
lá que pareceu que
erailcolina. Vitamina D 50. Eu acho esse
valor baixo. Não, não é baixo, mas pode
aumentar um pouco mais. Posso tomar a
cápsula de 50.000 UI por 3 dias? Pode,
pode sim. Se for pouco tempo, não tem
problema
não. Qual seria a melhor forma de
aumentar a serotonina além do 5 HTP?
o próprio triptofano, né? Porque o 5 HTP
já é um outro suplemento, você pode
tomar o triptofano também,
tá? E também os saudáveis de vida, né,
com meditação, sono adequado, isso
aumenta naturalmente o HTP, também
prebióticos, né? Porque boa parte
desse da serotonina vem do intestino.
Então se você comer uma dieta rica em
prebióticos, em fibras naturais, vai
aumentar a serotonina
intestinal. Exame para rins, urea,
creatinina. E em alguns casos a gente
pede também a um marcadora lá que é para
casos assim de dúvida que é o Puxa, me
deu branco
agora. Não sei por tava até falando
disso ontem pro
paciente. Se eu lembrar daqui a pouco eu
falo, mas é basicamente uré cretinina.
Alguns c pé de cleance de creatinina ou
depuração da creatinina, né, que é a
mesma coisa, que é um exame de urin de
24 horas,
tá? É isso
aí. Gente, vocês fizeram muita pergunta
hoje, não que eu ache ruim. Deixa eu
partir pros artigos
aqui. Deixa
eu Pronto.
Não, deja aqui. Pronto. Não, por que que
não tá
aparecendo? Ah, tá, agora entendi.
Pronto.
Ã, vamos lá.
Vamos discutir um tema que é muito
interessante, que é a suplementação pós
treino, se ela de fato funciona. Saiu um
estudo interessante que testou uma
fórmula que é uma combinação de vários
suplementos e
que trouxe informações interessantes aí
que de fato para pessoas que treinam
pesado algumas combinações podem ser
boas.
Então, esse estudo procurou verificar
uma estratégia nutricional que poderia
fazer diferença para pessoas que fazem
treino
pesado. Fez uma combinação específica de
ingredientes consumidos logo após
treino. Foram acompanhadas 20 pessoas
por seis semanas que praticavam
exercício de resistência três vezes por
semana.
A fórmula testada tinha 26 g de
proteína, tinha 23 g de
carboidrato e também incluíram 5 g de
creatina. Então carboidrato, proteína, 5
g de creatina, 1,8 g de HMB, que é o
hidroximetilbutirato, que é um princípio
ativo bom aí, mas um pouco caro, e 1000
unidades internacionais de vitamina D.
Então essa
combinação de proteína, carboidrato,
HMB,
creatina e vitamina D e
HMB, teve uma ação sinérgica tanto nas
reservas de
energia, melhora de força e
potência, preservação de massa
muscular e o teve um grupo controle que
tomou somutodestrina, que é só
carboidrato para comparar.
Então, o grupo que
tomou o suplemento com vários ativos aí,
depois de seis semanas teve uma redução
média de 2,5 cm de circunferência
abdominal na
cintura e o grupo controle teve uma
redução de 0,4 cm. Então, esse estudo
foi para ver essa parte mais de gordura.
O grupo da suplementação também melhorou
em média 2,9 cm no salto vertical. Então
fizeram esse teste de salto e o grupo
controle melhorou apenas 1,1 cm. Então
houve uma melhora real de potência e
força
funcional. Então outros parâmetros como
peso total, gordura total e massa magra
não tiveram diferenças significativas
entre os grupos.
E isso pode ter a ver com tamanho
pequeno do estudo, que eram só 20
pessoas. A média de idade dos
participantes era 54 anos. Então,
pessoas mais na faixa aí da idade média,
né? Pessoas mais maduras.
Então esse estudo demonstra que a
suplementação pós- treino com múlti
suplementos pode ter benefícios
reais, mas não é
mágico. Então vale a pena essa
combinação que eu comentei, apesar de
ser um estudo pequeno, que tem que ser
validado por outros estudos
maiores. Logicamente que eu não
recomendo que vocês façam uso desses
suplementos sem fazer atividade física
associado, porque vocês não vão ter os
bons
resultados. Valores dos exames, Antônio
Renato, não é esse objetivo nosso aqui,
né? Não é você brincar de médico, mas
você facilmente você acha isso no
Google, não precisa me perguntar aqui,
tá?
dose ideal de ncetil e acetil n tirosina
por volta de 200 a 500 mg por dia.
Tá bem, vamos falar do último estudo do
dia pra gente encerrar a live, tá? É um
estudo sobre alho e cebola para
prevenção de sarcopenia.
E o objetivo desse estudo foi estudar a
preservação da massa muscular no
envelhecimento usando eh curiosamente
alho e
cebola. São dois ingredientes muito
simples, como vocês
sabem. Esse estudo foi publicado na
China, foram 3600 pessoas com idade
média 66 anos. São pessoas já mais
idosas, idosas, não, mais com mais
idade, mas ainda não muito idosas,
né? Então, os pesquisadores queriam, os
pesquisadores queriam entender se existe
alguma relação entre o consumo de
vegetais do tipo álium, né, que é cebola
e o alho, e o desenvolvimento da perda
muscular da sacopenia.
Então, os pesquisadores descobriram que
pessoas que consumiam alho cru duas ou
mais vezes por semana tinham entre 31 e
41% menos risco de desenvolver
sarcopenia comparado com aqueles que
quase nunca consumiam óleo cru. De novo,
sacopenia é perda de massa muscular, tá?
Então, para a cebola crua, os números
foram similares, entre
26% e 41% de redução de
risco. Realmente eu não fazer a menor
ideia que alho e cebola poderia diminuir
sacopenia. Eles estão falando que tem
que ser alho e cebola cru, porque o
cozimento pode alterar ou destruir
benefícios, compostos bioativos.
Não sei qual mecanismo, não sei se se tá
falando aqui no estudo
mecanismo. E um ponto forte desse estudo
ele que foi um acompanhamento de 3 anos,
né? Isso torna os dados estatísticos
dele mais sólidos.
Ah, tá falando aqui, o alho e a cebola
podem proteger os músculos por conta dos
compostos, organosfurados e flavonoides
desses vegetais, que seriam
antioxidantes. Mas eu nunca tinha ouvido
falar que isso de fato poderia causar
prevenção de
sarcopenia. Então, através do combate do
estresse oxidativo e da inflamação,
então esses compostos organos sulfurados
e flavonoides poderiam estar reduzindo a
sarcopenia.
Então, essas substâncias também podem
reduzir a quebra de proteínas musculares
e, ao mesmo tempo, estimular o
crescimento de novas células
musculares. Então, pessoal, consumo mais
alho e mais cebola cru, especialmente se
você passou dos 60
anos. Coloque alho picado na
salada. Paciência que vai dar bafo, né?
Faça um molho pesto caseiro. Coloca a
cebola crua no sanduíche, na salada.
Para maximizar os benefícios do alho
depois de picar ou amassar, deixa
descansar por alguns minutos antes de
consumir. Isso permite que se forme a
alcina, que é um dos compostos mais
importantes paraa
saúde. Um ponto aqui desse estudo que
tem que ser lembrado é que ele foi feito
com uma população chinesa e os achados
podem não ser iguais para ocidentais,
tá? E se você tá preocupado com o odor
ou com hálito do alho e da cebola, você
pode mastigar salsa fresca,
hortelã e até mesmo um grão de café pode
ajudar. Beleza? Então vamos encerrar
aqui. Já estamos com uma hora de live
praticamente, tá? A cretinina, ela vai
até 1,2, tá? O limite da creatinina
normal. Aéa por volta de 40,
tá? Cadeira que você indica para ficar
na frente do
PC e como evitar problemas de coluna.
Olha, hum, parece que isso daí tem
vários pontos que tem que ser
verificados. Tem um camarada que tem um
canal no YouTube de uma cadeira certa e
também tem um site. Ele faz consultoria
gratuita de cadeira,
tá? Deixa
eu achar ele aqui para te passar o link.
Cadeira certa,
YouTube. Copiar endereço do link.
Caramba, ele já tá com 362.000
seguidores esse cara no
YouTube.
Pronto. Deixa eu mostrar
aqui. Vou deixar no grupo também do
WhatsApp,
tá? Escrever aqui cadeira certa.
Pronto. Dá uma olhadinha nesse youtuber
aqui que ele fala só desse
assunto. Obrigado e até a próxima semana
para você também, Antônio Renato, para
todos que estão acompanhando ao vivo. Um
abraço, um beijo no coração de vocês.